Congrats though you just turned 50 right
I just don't look it I get it they say
they say black don't crack well Asian
don't raisin that's what they say that's
on my new album years away from 40 man
tell me you know it gets it's better
right it gets cool right you forty it's
gonna be awesome right are you once you
turn fifty there you the guy on the the
law and yelling at children are you that
guy well how does that happen I'm more
the guy who just doesn't care anymore so
that hit me it out literally you know
you don't care where I mean I know I'm
wearing this suit now I'm looking fine
but you know you don't care where
everything I wear is like gap shirt gap
genes gap jacket it's comfortable I'm
not even kidding this is like literally
what I wore to work these are I don't
know if the camera can get this right
here these are first of all great point
thank you these are these are Kirkland
brand socks
not a sponsor just got a sponsor women
size six just it's the only thing that
lives and breathes on my oh yeah my foot
toes yep I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this